[Music]
know what would you do news what will he
do Oh Sabina hey Jake a mother hey it's
highly a man is trying to get a divorce
so by claiming his wife is a possessed
by the devil
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oppa I know it's
sad but it does me yes oh wow Oh God
Papa why I can't come up with a better
excuse it's like this business is a well
I would say all [ __ ] are I just I
mean I get it because I do why I get it
what was it I don't want to message that
someone that's possessed I know I know I
can see why it's not outlandish and a
what I guess listen to is for it because
because better declares that no shut up
because in Italy everything should shut
up
it's super crazy heavily influenced by
the Catholic or Christian Church yeah
like in the center they have a Vatican
City right there with the Pope did you
know that Saint Peter is actually buried
in st. Peter's Basilica he's considered
the first pope Jesus's disciple Nick
trace his lineage all the way to the
current Pope how about Santa Claus even
in school but his name is Saint Nicholas
Oh what if he had like he is a safe I
thought it was a horror story what if
Santa Claus it was one of Jesus
disciples that got kicked out and so he
just did his own thing oh that's a
double ya know the jelly joke that got
kicked out from heaven he was I know I
can't even believe I tried go ahead with
this college if I keep it though I'm not
saying [ __ ] you know why because he's
trying to steal Christmas away from
Jesus that's his day but he trying to be
like no it's my day I'm giving all the
presents outs all these years you can be
lighting people to find
this was even born on December 25th it's
not that's like a religious thing yeah
they move things around when was he born
I can't remember but there's an actual
date he was born 2017 years ago
everybody knows that we know he was he
died 2017 years ago although his
computer is like before Christ after
Christ like what was year 1 and what the
hell far back BC history [ __ ] Omega no
well this man he was claiming that ever
since 2000 Mario Luigi no 2007 since
2007 that his wife has been having some
very unusual behavior hell with that
[ __ ] for 10 years old decades I've been
doing with some [ __ ] for eight years so
his wife is known to be a devout
Catholic who is in over there mm-hmm
at one point she was able to knock over
a church pew and actually throw it
towards the altar by using one hand she
was to be angry that day she'd been
through the particle board was that when
I was in the fifth grade I picked up my
desk full of books and I threw it at
this kid yeah you were like wrong you
already I was a really big kid no okay
thank you thank you sir a chair bo 10
you threw a desk at one point an eternal
ugly yes yeah you're angry too
how come you got weaker than when you're
an elementary because I don't have my
anger issues anymore remember those
drug-free bands yeah the red things that
is like the club the club tonight this
[ __ ] [ __ ] he took that [ __ ] up and
he kept whipping with it and I asked him
to stop and I got so [ __ ] that I
really picked the shuttle up all but I
chucked it at him and I got suspended
for a [ __ ] week
yeah he didn't even get punished I took
the atom actually threw those did you
guys get a divorce - yes we did possibly
I mean so [ __ ] [ __ ] her sister like
a pre send in a monk like they were
witnesses to her own usually got a
collab going on yeah
a priest edible animal walk into a bar
I'm gonna be rappin out here what are
you going to do
no you're a Strigoi a chance I think you
felt like I met you an elephant there it
is I hear like using Rangers oh thank
you I got you yes he just had a little
small window handle and throw it in the
room
witnesses claimed that they actually
seen her levitate whoa
are the witnesses her friend or his
friends this article never specified I
wasn't witnesses on LSD why did she just
jump and they happen to look at him oh
yeah could I could levitate to for about
point by session she just does a trapeze
her unusual behavior was bad to the
point where they even tried to have a
prusik exerciser yeah yeah yeah but my
son accepted actually doing kettlebells
all kinds of [ __ ] you know he tried to
cure her over the years but nothing has
been Oh Julia you need all she tried
yoga to try powerlessness always
exercises even
yo bamboo the calisthenics didn't work
on that bear I know I know I know I
follow the Dark Lord I really want to
sound good if you believe in it in the
name of Jesus Christ I do follow I
believe I gotta believe in other
religions because I just want to make
sure that I'm okay Jesus got a sense of
humor come on man he made me love
basketball but broke both my ankles come
on that's pretty funny guy I think you
made you that's offensive
yeah that's bad superb you like the
human platypus right I know I'm a big
mistake what the [ __ ] am i a beaver does
going on today your grenade
uncircumcised penis Corey and grenade
that's a live one so the judge ruled
that all these things that her husband
is like pinpointing against her they're
like can't we use this as like really
good reason
yeah ripe you throwing as an offense
that's pretty technical
because be like yes we grant it because
there's some other just way to go what
it is we have a moral because a lot of
the things that this man is trying to
claim they're all very supernatural
things and so every time my dick your
serpent tongue wraps around my bone Wow
that'll be kind of cool
that's not yes I like those straws with
a squiggly squid before it goes to the
top it just wraps around your dick in
shape they don't match I really like it
but you're a demon but just finish me
off yes that sexy demon girl from scary
movies oh yeah oh yeah well you put the
bag over her yeah on ships after hearing
from the doctors and psychiatrists that
this woman was in good health
the judge was like okay well there
doesn't seem to be anything wrong with
her but it just seems like this
relationship isn't working out guys you
guys are cheating like et I just seem
unhappy
we'll just grant you guys a no-fault
divorce nobody's fault but you get a
divorce but it took him 10 years when he
was fighting for ten years I don't know
at what year he started to be filed
yeah
I don't know what room yeah what is the
difference between a divorce and an
annulment yeah wasn't thinking oh the
club yeah look at us
you're like an annulment Mike this is me
guessing I know that before you get your
marriage certificate you have to get the
marriage license but as you get up - I
know it's a weird scary point you get
your license I think technically you're
already married and if you don't do
anything if you don't actually have a
ceremony then I think your marriage can
be an old at that point if you don't do
anything if you do get a ceremony then
you can get your marriage certificate I
think that's how it works you have 90
days from the time you get your license
- when you have to get your marriage you
know what
just like driver's license you need to
go to [ __ ] marriage school because
there's so many divorces that means
people aren't doing it right that's true
hi we should go to marriage school and
let me make you happy you got to do a
marriage test and then you're ready to
get married then you get a marriage
license that's how Catholic churches
work if you want to get married at a
church that's why they don't believe in
divorce
mandatory you have to do a certain
amount a we board
there's counseling yeah I'm something
like that's good adult I like it to
answer your question David divorces an
annulment both have the same effects
where they dissolve the marriage however
they differ in how they treat the
marriage so when people get a divorce
they're still recognized as having been
married previously but when they get an
annulment it treats the marriage as low
and never existed why would I want to
that is [ __ ] awesome there's probably
certain like stipulations that it's time
that I wanna be a widow you can do
whatever you want so it says here that
some people do not want the stigma they
believe attaches to divorce others may
prefer an annulment for a religious
reason oh oh yeah I think like in some
states it's after you get married you
have one year to get it annulled or
something yeah this is a time thing that
after a year you could only do divorce
yeah so people ask you where ever
married you could say no then lie
because it never existed how can you do
that in lying sack of [ __ ] or you go I
was annulled whenever they take it off
the record you want to get like a record
or something so it could be your third
marriage but if it was an old it never
happened that's a [ __ ] you still
[ __ ] that [ __ ] trying to lie that you
did test control channel yourself
[ __ ]
people try to create all these titles
and things to [ __ ] erase their past
it's [ __ ] man it doesn't change
anything you see like it changes how to
field
we got an annulment so it's a senior
question about a time limit so if you're
filing an annulment because you're
married when you're under the age of 8
years of [ __ ] [ __ ] mess of the age of
18 you have to file an annulment within
4 years after you turn 18 so you get
married at 15 wait for your hair fall 92
and I'm gettin old
maybe maybe can be 15 17 maybe not 15
this is a good [ __ ] pilgramage you got
married at like 16 or 15 to some 30 year
old one was you're not under age what's
the rule look at images that joke was in
my letter book it hasta like nothing now
once this second date I think I'm going
to have a [ __ ] image of a pilgrim my
[ __ ] brains already if you are filing
for an annulment on the grounds of
bigamy you or your spouse can fall at
any time all the spells from the first
marriage is still alive that sounds like
some ancient [ __ ] like not sure that we
got to make mud about that gusu did not
thank me go pee no I know a Bigham it's
like some kind of like [ __ ] religious
thin like violation of the act of going
through a marriage ceremony well already
married to another person oh okay I ever
heard that phrase in a minute bigamy you
thinking bigamy small think of me Begum
is small the original wrapper hey guys
hope you enjoyed that episode please
don't miss a beat and subscribe if you
don't subscribe you don't know when a
new video is uploaded but for more
videos click up here
you
[Music]